morning guys yeah well Matt thinks
understanding the prisoner's life
stories is vital to getting the ethical
message across
really I'm a professional nosy person
right I dig into what people are
thinking and why they're thinking it so
I want you guys to tell me everything
how many times in doing so I mean four
times thirty or how old are you 34 34
yes 15 is right I've had a very long
drug addiction from a very young age
class a drug from the age of 10 so tell
me about this the work that you've been
doing with Gordon what's it done for you
inspire me show me I can do sales when
you're taking drugs or finger wise
you're getting it or duck no diamonds
you get it you left you left with
nothing you're left with empty things
you go fill that and this is feeling it
Anthony Kelly has been clean for nine
months but many of the prisoners in
Brixton have serious drug or alcohol
addictions ex-soldier David Jones got
hooked on heroin after leaving the army
this course has made me up you inside
makes me want to get up for the morning
makes me want to strive to be someone to
do something you know with my life I
think this is an important thing I'm
hearing from you and it's important
behind bad boys bakery that this isn't a
sob story isn't that people hear from
you mm-hmm they actually hear about what
Gordon's saying is discipline hard work
you need hard graft yeah doing something
doing something for yourself change
making a change yourself or my kitchen
Brigade have made huge progress former
drug dealer Hassan or is desperate to
put his old life behind him and resume
contact with his family
I don't know people say contoured a
future net you do not have future than
that but honestly if I did quote him
learn come upon it while I'm sorry and
I'll probably have a lot so is there
anything in what you've been doing here
with these guys that's kind of made you
think about whether you're gonna be back
here for a fourth time or not
now I'm gonna prove it around I
basically it's not true there lies your
criminal always a criminal you can
actually change your life you know it's
very moving
he's very moving hearing that it does it
does make me think you know that some of
your personal stories are very very
interesting and would be very
interesting as part of maybe a part of
the packaging or a part of a part of the
message that went out right guys matt
has already come up with an idea for a
marketing slogan I think there's
something around the idea of life
changing taste is powerful I think it's
emotional
we might want to think about it on the
pack to demonstrate the professionalism
of my team
the Wellington has to be cooked to
perfection however when you have them